german tennis legend boris becker has
been jailed for two years and six months
by a british court after being found
guilty of withholding assets following
his bankruptcy becker was convicted on
four charges on the britain's insolvency
act with a court ruling that he
prevented his insolvency administrator
from accessing money and property the
three-time wimbledon champion was
declared bankrupt by a london court in
2017 he had pleaded not guilty to all
charges
but for more on that story we are joined
by mark corrigan from dws sports uh
first mark i'm sure he can appeal he's
not going to jail straight away is he he
can appeal but he has gone straight to
jail so the appeal will be from
from jail so it's yeah an incredible
story uh
let's talk about this whole saga it
began as we've just heard in 2017 how
did that all
come about for jail to jail time as you
say it began 2017 um
he was declared bankrupt by a british
court own millions um around five or six
million euros um in loans
and he was then charged on 24 counts
under the british insolvency act one of
those included hiding assets from his
insolvency administrator and this was no
small fry this was hundreds of thousands
of euros that he transferred to his
ex-wife and his estranged wife to hide
it um a property in germany um shares in
a tech firm so
um he was then convicted earlier this
month on on four of those charges out of
the 24
and today came the sentencing and it was
two and a half years and so the end of
one saga in the beginning of a nightmare
scenario really for boris becker
definitely i mean he was i've been
following him since uh uh the beginning
when he first won wimbledon for the
first time he was the darling of the the
crowd there for many many years uh he
was a commentator on british tv uh for
wimbledon much loved in in in the
country that is a fall from grace isn't
it he was it's hard to understand how
beloved he was actually in britain i
mean he arrived on the scene 17 years
old unseeded first unseeded player ever
to win a singles title at wimbledon in
1985
and he was just the blue-eyed boy german
tennis beloved by the by the crowd he
actually i think he tried to play on
that today you may have seen in the
pictures there he was wearing a
wimbledon coloured tie on his way to
court but that didn't wash with the
judge deborah taylor and she's actually
actually sent down julian assange force
for jumping bail so she's she's dealt
with big reputations before and she
wasn't she wasn't intimidated by boris
and so yeah incredible from from the
darling of the centre court to um to now
to know the villain in a very different
court
mark and dw sports thank you
you